It was what we haven't talked about is
collaboration.
Yeah.
Eddie sort of creativity,
whatever you are.
Even if you're a fine artist,
it is about collaboration and you are
quite specific about what you bring to
the party,
the visual,
the imaginative.
But you always work with great writers.
Oh,
I have to because I'm not a very good
writer.
I mean,
I can write situation,
I can write the ideas,
I can have ideas about the characters,
but I don't write good dialogue.
It's very simple.
And so I always work with people who
can,
and I'd love working.
And I think that comes from,
you know,
once you're in a group like pies.
And,
um,
even though I was separate to some
degree,
it was always collaborative.
And I love working with other people.
And there's one reason I got bored with
animation because it's just me and the
paper.
And I love other people's ideas.
I love the,
the,
the need that I have to argue for why I
want something.
I've got to convince somebody else,
which is very important.
We're just saying I want it.
Um,
and so the whole process,
and I,
I love also,
and that's when the actors really become
wonderful cause you spent a year or so
writing it,
repairing it,
getting all,
everything ready and you go to work.
And now the actors come in and I spent a
lot of time choosing hopefully the right
people.
Uh,
and then they come in with very
different ideas about how to do a scene.
And so the daily business of shooting
becomes surprising all the time.
It's interesting.
Yeah.
It will be on your toes.
It's not,
it's not me just following my
storyboards process.
Yeah.
And it's an a seeing the process.
It's very organic consents and nature
comes in and rains when it's supposed to
be a sunny day for every,
these are shifting it.
So the whole process is alive.
It doesn't mean it's fun.
It's,
yeah,
most of the time I'm screaming and
tearing my hair out because it's not the
way I want it.
But that's,
but the point is to surround yourself
with people who are really good,
who are opinionated,
who don't,
who aren't.
Yes ma'am.
I watched so many filmmakers and see
they're surrounded by yes,
peak events and no,
I want people that argue with me.
They'd say,
what are you doing?
I mean,
I remember the first time we were doing
time Bennett's I'd got myself in a
corner,
literally shooting into a corner and a
whole set is back there and I couldn't
quite make it work.
And the prop guy came by the prop guy
and he said,
what are you doing terry?
And he prop guy talking to direct like
that.
Wait a minute,
there's a hierarchy hierarchy here.
But he said,
what are you doing here?
Why don't we just do that?
And basically,
is it Gabby?
And then he said,
I just didn't stop.
He's absolutely right.
And so ever since then I just listened
to everybody and I'm not,
um,
new robotic or insecure to reject all
these ideas because ultimately I'm smart
enough to know that I have the ultimate
power of deciding Yay or nay.
And I keep saying to people,
because people think I'm an old tour.
Uh,
I'm not.
I'm a field to,
yeah,
that's all I was coming from everybody.
And I get the credit or blame,
that's my job.